Jocelin is with us in New York hey
Joslyn how are you hi Dave how are you
better than I deserve what's up so my
husband and I financial life is a
complete wreck we have about $95,000 in
debt I have about 25,000 student loans
he has 12,000 of student loans
there's credit card debt in there a
$15,000 car loan we just started on baby
step one we don't have much we just
started but I'm just a little we've
never we've never addressed our our bad
decisions as far as like our finances
are concerned and I'm just scared that
the decisions that we made are just
going to ruin our life it's just really
scary me I won't have them married we've
been married for five years how old are
you 29 okay you are in an amazingly good
place right now because you have had a
very thorough oh crap moment
yeah you woke up and looked at this and
went right I heard and your voice and
your verb you see it's amazing
that is so good because that kind of
intensity will get you your butt cleaned
up because for you this is no longer an
intellectual exercise this is now
emotional yeah love it love it you are
in a really good spot because right now
you're like I don't really care what you
think we're doing this stuff I don't
mind I don't like it your Facebook
friend doesn't like it you don't care
you're about to get after it aren't you
mm-hmm yeah yeah you got word people
don't people's opinion doesn't matter
this is not an intellectual exercise
this is I feel stuck I'm overwhelmed I
never want to be here again oh crap I'm
getting out that is an awesome place to
be those are the people people like you
are the ones that have the most success
turning their lives around you're gonna
be great you're gonna be great what's
your household income so I make it I'm a
medical biller I make about $35,000 a
year cause my
husband my husband is a city cop so
right now he makes about 50 but when he
gets near five he'll be making about 105
when is that I'm here on year three
right now so we have two and a half more
years okay so for the next two and a
half years you guys make $85,000 a year
mm-hmm what are you on your house we
don't know how we're on your credit card
chain so as far as the house is
concerned days we literally just signed
the lease like two months ago and our
rent is two thousand one hundred and
fifty dollars good lord
yeah and yeah it was really stupid
I regret it and one thing that I did
want to ask me was I was thinking as I
ask your landlord what circumstances if
you got an if he could find a new tenant
would he let you out yeah so we were
gonna talk to her because we're very
close to her she's a very great person
um and I was thinking of asking my
parents if it's just my husband and I
they have a nice big house that would
fit us for at least a year and I was
thinking of asking them to move in with
them so he can pay off all her debt
within two years I think you pay it off
fast how much credit card debt have you
got again so we have about $25,000 I'm a
American Express but we refinance the
American Express and got like a personal
loan because interest rate with like 25
percent yeah okay if you want to move
home you can that's always my worst-case
scenario but I would get a one-bedroom
dumpy apartment at a minimum and get out
of this lease if you can without without
stiffing your friend I don't want you to
stiff the lease but I want you to get
your costs down
and let's get you on a written budget
I'm gonna send you a copy of the book
the Total Money Makeover which has got
all the steps in it of exactly what to
do when you're awesome you call me back
as you're walking through this and I'll
walk with you you can do this jump on
jump on the Facebook if you like that
thing and the Ramsay baby steps
community 250,000 people in there and
they'll walk with you and show you our
team is in their work people are it's a
good community to be in